TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Developer preview
three of Android Things
is now available, bringing
new features and bug fixes
to the platform.
For more details
on this release,
including Android Bluetooth
APIs and USB host support,
check out the post.
The GitHub for Santa
tracker has been
updated with the open source
versions of the web and Android
apps from December 2016.
Highlights and links to the
repositories are on the post.
This is the Material
Design color, too.
It's a new way to
create, share, and apply
color palettes to your UI.
The link is on the post.
We're increasing the
concurrent connections limit
for developers on the
Firebase Flame and Blaze
plan from 10,000 to 100,000.
Also in Firebase are
some new features
of Firebase Hosting
and the Firebase CLI
that makes configuring
Firebase on your web app
and working with multiple
environments much simpler.
Details and code
are on the post.
One last thing on Firebase.
We've released the
Firebase admin Python SDK,
focusing on Firebase auth
token minting and verification.
Code and links are
on this post as well.
The Google Neural Machine
Translation System uses
state-of-the-art
training techniques,
runs on TPUs to achieve some
of the largest improvements
for machine translation
of the past decade,
and is now generally available.
I've got three quick
updates about containers.
First, we've started
to make Kubernetes
1.6 available to Google
Container Engine customers.
Highlights include
increasing the number
of supported nodes by 2 and 1/2
times and fully managed nodes.
Second, we're making
it even easier
to manage Kubernetes clusters
running in Container Engine,
with significant improvements
to upgrading and maintaining
your nodes, including
automated node management
and node auto-upgrades.
And third, container-optimized
OS is now generally available.
If you're a Compute
Engine user, you
can now run your Docker
containers out of the box
when you create a VM instance
with container-optimized OS.
For details about all
these container updates
or anything else from
this week's episode,
follow the links in
the description below.
Please subscribe and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Thanks for watching this week's
episode of "The Developer
Show."
If you'd like to catch some
of our previous episodes,
they're right over
here on the left.
And don't forget to share
this with all your friends.
They'll appreciate you for it.